la parole est à monsieur jean claude
guibal merci monsieur le président ma
question s'adresse à monsieur le premier
ministre
le moyen-orient est à feu et à sang la
fiq croule sous le poids de sa
démographie et à nos frontières
le nombre de migrants ne cesse
d'augmenter les flux migratoires seront
sans doute demain l'un des phénomènes
majeurs de la planète globalisée
monsieur le premier ministre je souhaite
vous poser trois questions
depuis quelques jours 200 à 300 migrants
sont massés à vintimille à la frontière
franco italienne
ils ne sont que 200 à 300 à la frontière
mais elles y sont 57 milla est rentré en
italie depuis le début de l'année et ils
étaient cent mille à l'avoir fait l'an
dernier
ils sont par ailleurs près d'un million
attendre entre tripoli et benghazi
à moins de 100 milles nautiques des
côtes européennes de pouvoir suivre le
même chemin que je suis témoin que
jusqu'à présent la frontière entre
vintimille et menton est étanche au
moins sur ces axes principaux
il faut qu'elle le reste ne serait ce
que pour faire savoir à ceux qui
seraient tentés par l'émigration qu'ils
n'auront pas d'avenir en europe
ma première question monsieur le premier
ministre et de vous demander de nous
confirmer que la frontière
franco-italienne restera bien fermé bien
évidemment cette situation n'est pas
appréciée de nos amis et voisins
italiens et il faut les comprendre
les accords de schengen leur confie le
contrôle de 6000 kilomètres de côtes
européennes et la convention de dublin
leur impose en tant que pays d'entrée
d'étudier les demandes d'asile
monsieur le ministre de l'intérieur sur
réunit aujourd'hui à luxembourg avec ses
homologues européens pour organiser je
cite le renforcement de la solidarité
c'est ma seconde question monsieur le
premier ministre que propose la france
pour ne pas laisser l'italie supporter
seul la charge de ces flux migratoires
la solidarité européenne est nécessaire
elle ne suffira pas si les sources de
l'immigration ne sont pas taris mère si
la parole est à mme adam
nick girardin secrétaire d'état chargée
du développement et de la francophonie
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés
monsieur le député guibal oui nous
sommes face à une crise sans précédent
oui notre réponse doit être européenne
cohérente et globale en évitant à tout
prix les amalgames
nous avons aujourd'hui des migrants qui
arrivent on masse vous l'avait dit et
qui sont dans des situations
complètement différente d'abord il ya
les personnes ont besoin manifeste de
protection syrien et érythréens qui
doivent être accueillis accueillis sur
notre territoire selon les conventions
internationales c'est notre devoir
et puis il ya les migrants irréguliers
qui eux n'ont pas vocation à se voir
accorder l'asile
alors la réponse européenne à laquelle
nous travaillons repose sur deux
principes vous les avez évoqué d'abord
la solidarité et ensuite la
responsabilité la solidarité parce que
nous ne pouvons pas laisser l'italie et
la grèce seule facette pression nous
soutenons la proposition de la
commission européenne de mettre en place
un mécanisme de temporaire de recolle de
relocalisation pour mieux répartir et
c'est normal entre les états membres les
migrants qui ont vocation à se voir
accorder l'asile
et puis la solidarité parce que notre
solidarité ne peut être mise en oeuvre
que si certaines conditions de gestion
des flux sont respectées par les pays
qui le font la première rencontre est
cette réponse doit être fait vous l'avez
dit aussi en pleine coopération avec
l'italie et la grèce et cela passe par
la france pour la france par des
contrôles renforcés de la police aux
frontières
mais soyons lucides la réponse elle est
également à la cause et aux causes et
vous l'avez dit et nous sommes dans une
année 2015 où la solidarité
internationale devra être au rendez vous
et c'est le grand message d'addis abeba
en juillet prochain en ethiopie comme à
paris à la fin de l'année en 2015 parce
que les migrants sont aussi climatique
et cette solidarité internationale nous
allons l'amo la mesure et la france est
en avant postes pour mobiliser ses
partenaires internationaux
merci madame